- Good evening, everyone.
I just want to thank the
John F. Kennedy Foundation,
the entire selection committee,
also Daniel Finn, whom I had
the honor and pleasure to meet,
for being an inspiration,
and also Harvard University
for really investing in leadership
and the next generation.
This is an amazing and
prestigious honor for me
and I can truly tell
you that I never thought
that I'd be here.
When I think about John F.
Kennedy, President Kennedy,
and the legacy that he's left for leaders,
a few things have come to mind.
Change has arrived on the shoulders
of those bold enough to
believe in new ideas,
a realm of possibility, and
daring enough to take a stand.
We must continue to
believe in the possibility
of a brighter shared future
and the ingenuity that youth brings.
However, we must be diligent in protecting
our foundational values that
have made this nation great.
I believe in order to secure
our future as a nation,
we must be intentional in the pursuit
of building our next
generation of leaders.
When I was just a new mayor, I was blessed
to attend the Harvard
Institute of Politics
for New Mayors, and we spent a week here
learning about all the challenges
that we would ultimately face.
That experience had a
profound impact on me,
and I realized that I wasn't
the only person crazy enough
to take this position, but
also that there are many others
just like me that had a heart for service.
As part of that experience,
I had the privilege
of visiting the Presidential Library
right here on this very special grounds,
and it impacted me for a variety of ways.
As a young girl, I was inspired by
the legacy and the
leadership of John F. Kennedy
and he was not only bold, courageous,
but also had a magnetic personality
and the compassion that really, I think,
permeated all generations, and regardless
of your race or your
nationality of ethnicity.
I was equally inspired by
Mrs. Kennedy's dedication
to her family and her country.
I was so impacted that
I said a little prayer
that my husband and
family could experience
this library and they're
here with me on this evening,
so I'm thankful.
(applause)
The John F. Kennedy Library
stands as an institution
that is dedicated to
educating future generations
and providing the tools
and historical perspective
that we need to lead our communities
and to serve our country.
Although I have been equipped with one
of the best educations in the nation
and spent thousands of
hours in the library,
nothing could have prepared me
for the amazing journey of being mayor
of the city of Compton.
Since taking office, I've been challenged
at every side, I've been stretched,
yet I have not been uprooted
in my mission and my commitment
to my community because I truly believe
that every individual breathing deserves
a decent quality of life.
I'm committed to the children
and the families that I serve
and I believe that as a nation,
if we pull together, especially
at a time such as this,
that we can make it through
any obstacle or challenge
that we face together.
One of my core qualities
is my transparency.
I am not a politician.
I never thought I would be a politician,
and I can tell you that
I was just one person
that was committed to my community
that wanted to make a difference.
We have to encourage our young people
that have strategic minds to not only get
their education and
leave their communities,
but really come back to the same places
that have invested in them.
I believe that our next
generation of leaders,
they're present now, and that they need
the Daniel Finns and those
that have had the history
and the legacy to really
transform and transport
that information that we need in order
to activate in this special time.
It is young leaders like
President John F. Kennedy
and Reverend Martin Luther King
that remind me every single day
that age does not determine
my ability to make an impact.
Like my fellow honoree, Max Keener,
we must all be ever more committed
to helping the least of those,
those people that have been out-casted
and those communities that
have been counted out.
President Kennedy said it best.
If a free society cannot
help the many who are poor,
it cannot save the few that are rich.
I am truly honored to accept this award,
and although I don't
feel worthy of the honor,
I'm humbled to be here
and share this occasion
with my family and my team.
To my husband, Van, who has invested in me
as a person and a leader,
and that courageously
allows me to follow my dream, I thank you
because I wouldn't be here without you.
(applause)
And to Melissa, who's telling me no,
not to acknowledge her, my chief of staff.
I call her Command because she literally
is my right hand for everything in life,
and so I love you to pieces,
and to Debbie, who's also
my executive secretary
and been a friend for many many years
and her husband Tony.
We're a small team, but God really uses us
to do mighty things, and
so I'm really thankful
that you all are here to
share this special day.
Thank you all, God bless you.
(applause)